went to Nintendo World couldn't get a
slot but I go like this dude I think
about my dad what would my dad have done
in this situation and I know my dad
would have got in but I'm like but it's
a different era but I should be better
than my dad at getting into places and
doing stuff that I want to do for my
kids because the student surpasses the
teacher right that's what we all hear
the students got to surpass the teacher
right so I walk up they're scanning and
I go
I see they're scanning we're
we're not we're not right
because we'll be when we can't
get in and right now it's before that so
there's always a plan that we can have
so I woke up and I said you know what oh
my my wife has it on her phone and
I don't have the thing with me uh I
don't have it downloaded and she says oh
where's your wife and I said she's
actually a few back but she had the
stroller
um can we just like wait for her here
off to the side she says sure just wait
over there points behind her and I go